rosny sous bois on peut découvrir des
surprises telles que ces petits
pavillons de banlieue havre de paix
niché entre les aux immeubles
malheureusement il est prévu que ces
maisons de la rue philibert hoffmann
soient toutes détruites
en cause les travaux du tronçon est de
la ligne 15 du projet du grand paris
l'ouvragé déclaré d'utilité publique les
23 habitations concernées dans
lesquelles vivent en majorité des
personnes âgées l'on a pris brutalement
par une lettre envoyée par la société du
grand paris
la sgp le riverain jean françois boulay
est catastrophé on a reçu il est
ordinaire voyez même pas recommandé
voilà donc cette lettre a dit qu' on a
besoin de vos terrains et nous on est
rentré dans la maison en 99-2000 quoi
juste à ce moment là voilà donc ça fait
un peu plus de vingt ans que nous sommes
là et on était venu à pourvoir être
tranquille pour la fan logement à partir
voir on dit bah écoutez monsieur vous
partez by van on imaginer quand même le
choc
tu as a représenté y la déception bien
sûr jean françois boulay a organisé une
pétition et fédère les habitants sous le
choc j'ai croisé des gens sont trottoirs
moi je revenais de chercher mon pain
qu'ils avaient de la lettre la main et
il pleurait une personne de 80 ans
pleurait en lisant la lettre
c'est des gens qui vivent dans leurs
pavillons ont leurs souvenirs pour leurs
habitudes qu'on leur patrimoine affectif
et tout ça et on leur dit vous partez en
plus on vous raconte tout moi j'espère
avoir la force de négocier vous il ya
peu près comment mais y ait des gens
comme 87 cents comment ils vont négocier
il y a deux ans le tracé ne devait
menacer qu'une école mais des études
complémentaires ont estimé qu'un ouvrage
appelé antoine mans pouvait être réduit
de 200 m en passant par un nouveau
périmètre la société du grand paris a
choisi ce scénario avec l'accord de
l'ancien maire de rosny sous bois
mais les habitants n'ont pas été
informés nous avons pu consulter un
document d' usage interne de la sgp
il prend acte du fait que l'ancien maire
a demandé de ne pas initier de contact
avec les propriétaires avant avril 2020
soit avant les élections municipales
un secret qui révoltent l'adjoint au
maire pierre olive et karel mis devant
le fait accompli et un véritable
déchirement non seulement d'avoir appris
de manière assez incidente le nouveau
projet mais également l'impact humain
que cela va avoir sur les résidents qui
sont là depuis tant d'années et on a
découvert au détour d'un compte rendu de
réunion qui a eu lieu au mois de juillet
2019 que l'ancien maire avait demandé à
la société du grand paris de ne n'avoir
aucune communication avant le mois
d'avril 2020 à l'époque n'avait pas
encore la perspective du confinement
donc c'était post élections municipales
lui il ya la ligne 15 mois à côté de
chez moi j'ai la ligne 11 donc n'importe
qui peut être concerné et on va bien que
si les plus humbles qui trinque à chaque
fois aujourd'hui jean françois boulay se
sent bien seul
j'écris au grand paris pour demander une
explication ils ne répondent pas j'ai
écrit à banier peau des fesses
elle ne répond pas je suis tout seul
contactée la société du grand paris
explique que ce nouveau tracé permet de
diminuer les nuisances du chantier est
de réduire sa durée
elle explique connaître qu'au tout début
des négociations et que pour cette
raison un contact téléphonique n'a pas
encore été initié la sgp promet
d'organiser une réunion en janvier et
d'accompagner chaque propriétaire au cas
par cas
reste la détresse des habitants dont la
maison et la tranquillité vont
s'effondrer